just curious what you shot on a c300 and
then also use the 5d I found the fuzzy
kind of hard especially at twelve noon I
like I can't look at that LCD and get it
focused well enough and I know that
there's some like attachments that you
can put on there which I found out in
retrospect to create almost like a
viewfinder for the LCD and I didn't
really figure out the filters as well
with that camera I really loved the c300
it was heavy as all get out and I know
they're marketing it as like this
lighter camera like that my girl arms
after a while just would start sinking
and then I would use my elbow and place
it into my hip like as if my hip is that
the tripod to take the weight and sort
of curve around the camera all day long
and then especially kimani because we I
mean I don't want the story about kimani
to be like this adult viewpoint you know
I want it to be from her perspective so
I was constantly in this sort of plie of
sorts what you know shooting kimani
hunched over and yes did you have
another TP or it was all yeah okay I did
um I was like going through all the the
cameras i got i got on off on a tangent
that way i were used also the bolex
which I didn't shoot on the bollocks we
had a do grau the amazing Eddie growl
who shot a single man he shot a
suffragette the Meryl Streep movie that
just got released and so he was our DP
for for Ron primarily
and jb i can't pronounce his last name
yeah i saw the lot yeah i have it here
somewhere too sorry JV but he he he did
a lot of our we shot on the lumix a lot
of our traveling shots we had we got a
car mount and did that he did a lot of
that he did some b-roll of of Ron's
garden got like some beautiful amazing
stuff there another DP John yikes I
can't remember his last name either but
he came in for for one day so but
eighty-five ninety percent is when there
was like one on one interview stuff or
in the garden with the characters it's
it's me the GoPro the our drone shots
was our producer christopher Leggett he
got those he's just like a tech head so
I'm afraid of the drones weren't sure if
it was yeah if you had a helicopter or
what so that looks great the over shots
of the garden when you're when you were
in South LA and there were some you know
police shots and different things what
was your protocol for shooting some of
that I mean how fearful were you not of
just a neighborhood but the police as
well not wanting you to shoot them right
well the thing is it's like there are
police driving around South Los Angeles
like there are like you know buses going
by in Hollywood it's just a constant
presidents insane with the helicopters
and I never really felt like anything
was going to happen to me if I aimed
camera as long as I'm not antagonizing
anyone so yeah and as far as being
afraid in that area I think that's kind
of like
a two-fold question because I know that
the crime rate is higher there so that's
in my mind while i'm there but it also
by walking around any part of the city
with 14 thousand dollars worth of
equipment a girl all by myself with one
eye covered and earphones on and can't
see behind me you know i'm always going
to feel a little edgy you know so I
definitely was out saying more on edge
than I I would be but it's hard to
determine because I feel like I'm a
little ballsy in that sense like
especially if I'm trying to tell a story
that's not about me and for a I believe
a greater cause that I'll put myself in
two situations that are you know worth
worth not my life but you know my life
but and lastly just just wrapping up
here were you surprised though by how
many people were intrigued by a female
with all this gear on walking down the
street I know you said before people
were hesitant but where there's some
that were just like wow what are you
doing like what are you making I did get
that I definitely got people stopping me
on the street to ask about about the the
equipment and what I'm doing and I got a
lot of support to sister out in the hood
with my you know with my gear and like
hey tell my story tell my story you know
it's like you gotta eat a listen to my
story I got a lot of that too like okay
let me take notes I might but I'm busy
right now I can't do your story give me
your information but I did get a lot of
support out there I think people I
thought it was actually a really great
to be sort of an example in South LA of
like not only just like a black woman or
mixed woman making a movie as an example
in the area where there's no film school
that I know of in South LA and then also
being female and hopefully empowering
other women that even if they're not
going to be a filmmaker just seeing
someone do something that looks like out
of the box or something that we don't
see
regular regularly that I I think that it
definitely was inspiring for for people
to see absolutely thank you thank you
you